تمثل معركه باخموت رمز المعركه بين
الاوكرانيين والروس هي اطول معركه منذ
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا واكثرها دمويه
هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه اعترفت في تقريرها بان روسيا
حققت بعض المكاسب داخل ضخمه قوات العدو
حققت نجاحا في تحركاتها الراميه الى
اقتحام مدينه باغموت يسيطر المدافعون عنا
على المدينه ويصدون العديد من هجمات العدو
مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه قال ان كيف
تسيطر على ثلث باخت فقط لكنه نفى ان
القوات الروسيه تحاصر المدينه قائد مجموعه
فاجنر كان قد قال في 20 اذار مارس ان
عناصره في الصفوف الاماميه يسيطرون على ما
يقارب 70% من باخموت من جهتها السلطات
الاوكرانيه لم تؤكد هذه المعلومات كيف
تتخذ موقفا دفاعيا منذ خمسه اشهر لكنها
تؤكد ايضا انها تعتزم شن هجوما مضاد قريبا
مستغله الانها
القوات الروسيه تقدمت في الاشهر الاخيره
شمال وجنوب المدينه ما تسبب بقطع طرق
الامداد عن القوات الاوكرانيه كما تمكنت
من السيطره على شرق بخموت ايضا معهد دراسه
الحرب الامريكيه اعلن الاربعاء ان القوات
الروسيه تسيطر على ما يقارب 65% من باخموت
بعد تقدمها في الشرق خلال الايام الماضيه
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه قالت ان
الخسائر في المدينه حتميه لكن خسائر الروس
اكبر بعده مرات